all right let's get into this week's
hatred mail quick reminder about what
hatred mail is because we cling to our
guns and our God but somehow totally
cool with a billionaire who wants to
assault our wife right patriot man
written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom alright so if I have to sort of
sum up the theme of this week's hatred
mail we've had a lot of more alt-right
hatred mail which is less religious in
nature this time we're going more in the
direction of the religious based Patriot
mail take a listen I notice that there
are a large number of homosexuals
associated with continual attacks on the
president why is that I don't know do
they have a little club going jude seven
through eight seven as Sodom and
Gomorrha and the cities around them in a
similar manner to these having given
themselves over to sexual immorality and
gone after strange flesh are set forth
as an example suffering the Vengeance of
eternal fire eight likewise also these
dreamers defile the flesh reject
Authority and speak evil of dignitaries
whenever people just throw scripture at
me my eyes immediately glaze over and I
just don't care i I just tuned out
immediately because who cares what what
Judas seven I don't even know what that
was Jude seven and eight what is that I
don't know it seems like a lot of work
to you gotta go find the passage yeah
copy and paste it over I wouldn't be
willing to do that oh these people are
religious enough that they don't need
copy and paste I mean they just know
this stuff off the top of their heads
like the Westboro Baptist Church people
you can give a middle finger to the hey
treats by using the coupon code hey tree
at forty if when you go to david
pakman.com slash membership you pick a
membership monthly yearly whichever on
the second page of the signup there's a
coupon code field and if you use the
coupon code hey tree at 40 you'll say 40
percent and
is a big fu to the hatreds who would
like to see the show fail